[Music]
it's time for et's late-night roundup
your quick catch up on all the best
celebrity scoop after dark it was the
weirdest TV finale since lost Jimmy
Kimmel addressed the Oscars Best Picture
mix up in his monologue Monday night he
says he was just as shocked as we were
so we're sitting here you just gotta
figure well you know the host will go on
stage and clear this up and then I
remember oh I'm the host I'm standing
there like an idiot feeling bad for
these guys but also trying really hard
not to laugh the fiasco was also tackled
on The Late Late Show James Corden
spoofed the moment with a Long Island
parody is to the ones who lose here's to
the ones who ha
Oh who switched that envelope more music
over on the tonight show Jimmy Fallon
and Ed Sheeran absolutely Slade
classroom instruments Nashville Star
Connie Britton sat down with Stephen
Colbert on the late show her first
appearance since her character Rayna
Jaymes died in a car crash during last
week's episode written affirmed Rayna is
definitely dead but she's open to
bringing her back in other ways she's
really dead but I think the twin sister
idea is not bad what if you know I mean
it's Nashville anything could happen
what if the long-lost twin sister comes
back oh and she's such a devil
you